bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors à partir
d'aujourd'hui daksi nation obligatoire
pour tout votre profession comment vous
accueillez cette obligation demandé par
le gouvernement
avant tout nous sommes très clairs une
somme pour la vaccination mais contre
son obligation est actuellement où nous
avons des professionnels qui sont dans
la contrainte et le titre de votre sujet
aujourd'hui le dinh inde et les
soignants sont dans la contre 1 nous
nous sommes plus dans la volonté de
l'explication
pour essayer de convaincre les
professionnels
de cette vaccination puisque là il ya
encore beaucoup de professionnels des
ombres d'autres qui sont toujours dans
cette hésitation
légitimes ou non ce n'est pas le débat
mais il faut entendre leurs craintes et
justement
comprendre pourquoi ils hésitent encore
à se ferme at il alors pourquoi
justement à votre avis est-ce qu'ils
hésitent
où il ya beaucoup de
[Musique]
d'hésitations sur le mac sans lui même
sur le fait qu' on les a stigmatisé
pendant des mois et des mois au tout
début de la pandémie des professionnels
n'ont pas eu l'équipement nécessaire ils
ont couru après les masques avec des sur
blues et puis un problème qui date
depuis des années des années sur le
métier d'ambulancier sait qu'on n'a pas
la reconnaissance auprès du patient un
ambulancier
il soit dans le domaine du privé ou dans
le domaine du public parce qu'il ya de
ces deux fonctions là n'est pas reconnue
auprès du patient c'est une catégorie
août et du technique et proféré
justement on estime qu'un bécane
ambulance est sûre dessin n'est pas
vaccinée est ce que c'est une proportion
qui vous semblent justes
alors du privé je n'ai pas trop de
données chiffrées en tout cas pour le
domaine médical bien évidemment qu'on
est à peu près sûr cet ordre là puisque
les dans le 2 au total ce spitalier sont
vaccinées entre 90 et 95% justement sous
cette fameuse contrainte cette pression
qui est subie par par les hospitaliers
alors si des professionnels donc ne
peuvent plus travailler faute de
vaccination quelles vont être les
conséquences sur le terrain
en tout cas dans le domaine du public
ils seront suspendus moi j'ai beaucoup
de retours de centres hospitaliers qui
dansait déjà décollé qui ne sont plus à
partir d'aujourd'hui me sur le planning
ils sont en suspension suspension de
salaire et suspensions travail
un mot peut-être sur le moment
lorsque la crise est cosy daf rappeler
de frapper de plein fouet notre pays
votre profession a été très sollicité
est ce que le protocole qui avait été
mise en place à l'époque a permis de
limiter la casse
tout
ça n'est pas permis et la casse
j'ai beaucoup professionnels
[Musique]
qui ont démissionné laurent la pandémie
parce que justement il n'y avait pas la
sécurité ou de prise en charge n'y avait
pas de message clair dans la protection
nécessaire vous avez eu deux dents dès
le démarrage
et des professionnels qui ont dû courir
après celle protexpo pas voir voit ce
qu'il fallait qu'il donne qu'il se place
dans quelle mesure et pouvait prendre en
charge les patients qu'aux vite parce
que on est en première ligne
alors aujourd'hui qu'est ce que vous
dites au gouvernement
opposition à l'éclair pas un seul
collègue doit d'être suspendu oui à
l'apport nous préférons convaincre le
contraire
puisque nous sommes dans une phase où
il admissible
à jouer soit mis à la porte cette façon
et la riposte que vous prévoyez face à
cette mesure
on laisse au libre choix à tous peu ou
les établissements et tous les collègues
de pouvoir sont mobilisés
[Musique]
essayé de me battre pour homps et
reconnaître le fait sont quand même des
professionnels de santé il faut
cependant battu pendant des mois et des
mois durant la crise que d'être traité
de la sorte
et pour conclure qu est-ce que cela dit
finalement sur la manière dont
gouvernement gère la crise sanitaire
la crise sanitaire c'est grâce aux
hospitaliers qu'elle a été géré
voilà c'est tout si vous peut se dire
hey vous avez vous avez là un
gouvernement l'un messages les messages
contradictoires
durant un an et demi un coup fallait pas
mettre les masques un scoop allait
mettre les masques et cetera et cetera
vous avez vous à nous a donné des
messages rejoint son beau blanc le
lendemain c'est et loire la crise n'a
été généré par les hospitaliers et par
tous les professionnels de santé et à ce
titre on doit un petit pot de
reconnaissance et un petit peu de
respect merci beaucoup à vous françois
et sans violence et secrétaire général
de l'union syndicale départementale cgt
de la seine maritime